hi everyone it's Jerry this is another
group of five puzzles all of them are
endgame positions with white supply and
it's up to you to determine the best
continuation in each case so in this
first one go ahead pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to this one is
to first promote your pawn to Queen it's
very important to take into account that
white is not the better side here if
given the opportunity
the Queen is just going to start
checking that white King around and so
forceful moves are necessary promoting
to a queen with is forceful forcing King
takes Queen and at this point we just
have back-to-back Forks starting first
with the bishop d5 Queen takes Bishop in
now Knight b6 winning the Queen and now
drawing this position so that's the
solution to puzzle 1 moving on to the
second once again white to play pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is to first play King to b6
watching over this pawn and trying to
get to be 7 so that pond can be pushed
king to c8 the only way to stop that and
now it's very important not to play King
to c6 that's actually stalemate and
similarly pawn to e6 taking away that
flight Square from that black King will
result in stalemate and so King to c5 is
the move at that point in which case
King takes pawn is now met with pawn to
e6 what does this move doing exactly
well it's allowing white to regain
opposition for example if now king c6
excuse me King c8 we now have king c6
King d8 King d6 King to e8 well we can't
go to e6 but we just push our pond
forcing the King out and then we sneak
our King in we're going to be able to
promote on the next turn so that's the
solution to puzzle two moving on to the
third one once again white to play pause
the video see if you can find the best
continuation for white ok the solution
to this one is king to c7 it's very
important not to make this tempting B 6
advance because black has a way out they
have a sneaky way to draw this position
with playing their King to a8 playing to
b6
result in a loss playing to the coroner
however will allow stalemate
possibilities after King goes to the
corner now there's nothing great that
white can do King c7 is stalemate if the
pawn pushes we have King V 8 at which
point King b6 is a stalemate and any
other white king move will allow King
takes pawn and so it's important not to
make this pond advance but rather King
c7 forcing King a and now King b6 this
right here is the square that the king
is needing to get to looking to now make
use of that a7 square if allowed to get
there if the King plays to c7 or c8 we
just have king a7 and then push a few
times to Queen and so I guess putting up
as much resistance as possible on the
black side King to a8 and we still just
push our pond finally the King has to
come out and then king a7 followed by
queening so that's the solution to
puzzle 3 moving on to the fourth once
again white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to this one is
e 5 in fact this is the only save in
this position white can only draw in
this position of course the black King
getting ready to grab this pawn it's
important to not allow that to happen
if for example King c2 King d4 what's
going on here is that black will be able
to regain opposition because they can
expend a pawn move d5 and now the White
King has to move and we're seeing now
that the black king is making progress
and black will be able to win this
position however by playing a 5 right
away enforcing pawn takes now we connect
now we can make this next very key move
King to c1 it's very important to play
that square any other square will result
in the loss King to c2 is met with King
to c4 black has the opposition black is
the one who's taking away these
advancing squares from the White King
King D to King d4 same thing going on
and so by playing to King King to c1
placing the King
on the same file as the black king and
having there be an odd number of squares
in between white is taking a distant
opposition getting ready to now meet
moves like King c4
with King c2 King d4 with king d2 and if
this were a variation we're just going
to either have the Kings going back and
forth just kind of dancing back and
forth and eventually black is gonna have
to make some progress to push the pawn
and y can just draw this position making
certain that if the King must retreat it
retreats to a square that's on the same
file as this pawn the move that meets
that criteria is King to e1 King f3 King
F 1 e2 King e1 and now this is going to
turn out to be a draw by either
stalemate or by winning the pond so
moving on to the last one puzzle 5 once
again white to play pause the video see
if you can find the best continuation
for white ok the solution to this one is
rook to f7 landing a fork Queen takes
rook and now a really neat finish G
takes H you don't grab the Queen
grabbing the pawn is the only one that's
going to save the game in this position
if Queen the g8 well that would just be
a horrible blunder you wouldn't want to
do that but the reason I point that out
is because any other move that's made by
black is gonna result in stalemate the
white king has no legal moves and so
that's the solution to puzzle 5 and
that's all for this video as always I
hope you're able to take something away
from it take care bye